okay uh I don't know which mountain
there's a few mountains around me this
one is kind of like plateaued but spiky
in the middle a little bit why I got a
dino I could kill myself on so you want
to stab yours which I stab mine I'm
gonna go hug the Ruby rumber offs
prehistoric crack
are you by the lake I'm by the lake and
there's a rock like right near me
describe the rock there's a rock okay
it's rock is it the lake where there's a
fort in the middle of the lake I don't
see a fort Oh poopy the sport might be
in the middle of the lake I don't know I
can't tell well I mean it's either
surrounded by water Lord snow it is um
release question shot oh it's a
Brachiosaurus but it's not really cuz
that's how I they're called how close
can I get to this Dino before it kills
me okay I'm I'm kind of sitting in the
water's edge yeah where are you come
around by the tree which tree oh wait
we're rid of Wade my friend like this
knife I'll kill you with this knife also
wait wait what
you look so threatening with it oh god
you look so angry and also like a Ken
doll you're the most handsome devil I've
ever seen
yeah I'm sure you look just like me I
like how you're holding that knife like
a gun it really is threatening what
what's going on with your face oh my god
are you okay how do you die oh yeah wait
okay yeah oh wait Oh is he where we
comes through your pain we should have
been the best of friends Wade you have
one messed up butt cheek thank you you
want to swap positions all your pants
are still not working right and your
head is broken hey I ripped open my
pants walls what all God you got one of
my tie
huh oh you're spinning around in your
skull beautiful God no I get it a little
bit Oh mice is spinning around what do I
look like wait get wait sit on my face
it's the only time I'm gonna ask you
that way okay oh god your butt is
bleeding through the hello everybody my
name is Margo barn
welcome to beasts of prey hi Wade hey
Mark I got something in my eye I think
it's part of your butt hahaha I think
your butt got in my eye and that's how I
got white and turned inside out I
thought you were doing the
Shoal voice cuz you're like you got real
muffled when you started to say that oh
right nowhere near the land on dinosaurs
well what if there were Sambi dinos that
would be so cool
X game that needs to come out why aren't
there zombie dinosaurs you know there
aren't enough dinosaur modes in games in
general but there should be zombie dinos
come on
alright so this is a completely new game
at least for me it's still an early
alpha but Wade has been playing it so
Wade I'm once again I'm gonna rely on
your expertise to try to get me through
this game alive so here's the thing okay
here's this knife yes you guys cut wood
from trees and you pick it up with E
wait am i all my god you did you cut one
solid cylindrical chunk out of it and
once you collect enough wood you go and
hit some rocks and then you pick up your
rocks
right don't add oh no more resources
here you took all the wood oh they're
only got one what there was only one
wooden that tree it's checking it there
hey here's your Stegosaurus I know I'm
not interested in the Stegosaurus right
now I'm a bullet but I will spread my
love of dinos later yeah this for some
people for some reason this tree has
like tons of wood and that giant one
over there dad nothing well someone must
have been milking it for all it was
worth
someone was milking its wood is that
what you're saying you know your milk
trees yes I know exactly in a part it's
with nipples with bar that's bark
nipples bark nipples it's true you can
milk anything with why do we always have
weird things come up with nipples well
we have weird things coming up with
dildos penises butts any part of the
human body that can be considered weird
let's order private or private you think
our butts penises and nipples are
private in this channel our heart but I
mean they should you are a youtuber you
were sell your body for four views
anytime you can oh I know don't actually
do that wait what I hear leads down a
bad road those are you sure yes I'm
fairly sure feels like a good thing to
do no it's not trust me you don't want
to get started you know how many people
are dying for me to start the market
porn channel I thought your name was
market porn in this game when you popped
up no its markup ooh
not markup or where do you go out I lose
you know one right here you couldn't
lose me I'd never let myself lose you
you're like sharpening your nails with a
knife thank you I know I'm also chopping
off the front of my fingers huh so how
many of these woods do we need no more
resources well if it takes 24 to make a
crafting table I've got hello oh my god
can we combine uh if I do how to drop it
I would say yes how do we in are you
dropping it right now
yeah well I'm chopping it out of a tree
you're just lazing about there oh oh you
are there's no tree there yes there is a
tree there you blind get right where
you're at right now yeah right here
right where I'm not I chop here there's
a tree but no more resources Osment my
screen it on it trust me there was a
tree there you may be too big there's a
tree there yeah there's a tree there of
course there's a tree there but there
wasn't one here you are insane and you
need to be put down so don't tempt me
Lister your wood no my wood don't grab
my wood wait no give it back I want to
put my hand on your woods you badly man
you know any other time I would let you
put my hand your hand on my foot bloody
put my hand on my wood you know mother
father wouldn't be happy about that or
not father father mother father mother
mother father father you know mother
father was a complicated man don't even
the context of that I know your brothers
were twin brothers who are trying for
stew fight each other
and with father mother yeah our mother
father one person was both our mother
and our Father it was a really weird
birth it was a really drunk birth drunk
bad know who God is not a good no God no
I'll forget I said anything will that at
that out bury that is offensive
no it's not a fence it's not even made
of wood
all right does anyone even know what
elmer fudd is I keep saying things like
that never was like good mark you're so
insulting how dare you it does not hold
me did you know Bugs Bunny calling Elmer
Fudd Nimrod was where Nimrod gained a
negative connotation really yeah I've
had that bad of a country no no Nimrod
is a famous hunter I forget what period
he's from but either Greek or something
like that but yeah Nimrod is always
majestic and beautiful
does he have nipples I'll take a look I
don't know any under there get under
there I'm gonna get under it I'm gonna
get a good look at him if he steps on me
well I dye it you might okay but no
guarantee to that no guarantee there's a
real good view right here that's some
quality Dino but oh I've also said Dino
poun without have been weird
Dino poon Dino poon I don't even know
what the poon is if you know what I mean
I don't either
I don't either is kid-friendly show kid
friends yeah this is not pure graphic
replace every word of poon into teddy
bear and kool-aid yes and kool-aid
Dino kool-aid teddy bear Dino Dino teddy
bear either way I got 24 can I make a
crafting table oh I need to make planks
okay yes make wood planks than you can
uh wood plank okay I'm gonna make 24
wood planks repeating to a lot of
resources oh god this is gonna take
forever
I told you like I told you the crafting
was tedious oh when can I lose my mind
god I don't it's been a while since we
played in we actually um okay last one
we played like just the two of us not
just like propping or something like
that was seven days to die and we're
actually just trying to get that working
but seven is to die has gone through how
many updates it's an eight point seven
right now at least seventeen I think it
was at five point three when we last
played something like that yeah and
there was like nothing different like
we're still and we had just as much
trouble trying to play the damn game
yeah we still can't connect Oh can't
connect to each other but this game
actually is working and it's got dinos
and it's turning tonight should we be
worried about that um only if we run
into Raptors or Raptor like things
everyone's like
doesn't raptors those are dining caucus
those are dining caucus yeah we don't
know any caucus from your Raptor caucus
I don't know the dining [ __ ] from the
rabdi caucus don't you know your Dino
Cox God isn't there a sign a scientific
field for uh theorizing dinosaur mating
I'm sure there is a third say Dino Cox
no well I mean it's a long-standing
Latino mating but I mean specifically
okay I got a crafting table either way
what do I do with my people that
specialize in ever there's probably
Polly get off the Dino mating oh that's
like a whole new level of bestiality
right yeah I know it's like oh you
little the Archaeopteryx you you what
are you even talking about you know way
too much about this what's an
Archaeopteryx what is it our key apps
really know that because I used to have
this boy took my table I didn't touch
your table well it's gone I was itching
my beard wasn't you press you press e on
it maybe it up oh you press I and then
you press you what the hell Chris you on
the table to use the table okay all
right wait
bonk do you see this table yeah also
this is a magical table Oh if you break
rocks you can unidentified or and this
magical table is what identifies the
aura for you in some magical way I know
it's amazing
oh we need oh oh oh we need torches how
do we do half this stuff Wade I need my
loss help me everyone out there watching
thinks I'm an idiot already we need to
go find rocks so pick it up it's dark I
really don't have much shopping all
right I picked it up got my dice I'm
ready that does last a while oh god is
it real-time day/night no not real time
but it'll be a while
is it like Rus day night it's probably
like ten minutes of night oh good can we
just hop raid there's like a thing
there's anybody in there can we steal
their [ __ ] we can try can we steal their
poop we're doing their teddy bears in
kool-aid is what I'm trying to say okay
they'll steal their Dino kool-aid well
how did they build all this is a lot of
stuff
a time and effort is anybody in there
is anybody gonna Myrtle eyes us nobody's
in there right now the only thing they
have it looks like it's a part of a
staircase what what kind of oh what oh I
thought I got hit wait can I sneak in
right here yeah I got in I'm in got to
do this other side other side it's
totally easy to get in dude there's a
chimney here yes I heard it that is one
big-ass furnace that's more like it
I like how this game realest what don't
you see where you got in well I right at
the front door just go to the left of it
you dingus really why am i teaching you
about this game just right here wait
right here
golly gee jiminy Christmas generate this
base you could get in like this I don't
know cuz they're dumb and that's why
they died how do you even make walls
like this why is it nighttime oh why is
the lake glowing of you make walls like
this with the raw rock that you find oh
that's easy I go out and take rocks all
the time and I build concrete structures
those an homage to I'm glad you do that
now you should do that for us okay but
how I don't even see a rock what I'm
surprised it's dark and scary I don't
even know where you are I went out
holiday so this is about the place that
we were in to a bunch of Raptor look at
the dinosaur over here whatever what is
that call what I don't know I can't even
see a dino it's in the water oh that's a
whoo buddy wampum oh the whoo buddy
walked them no hoody wampum Ruby welcome
whoo buddy whooping whoo buddy whooping
yes whoo buddy welcome
Hoopa do you open a source now remember
who buddy walkable Shores a sort well
said that's Schmidty werben jaegerman
jensen and sores oh I should have no
smitty werben busy with your Jetsons
woman ooh sores do you not even know
what that how to say that sponge robbers
well I thought it was gonna come after
you for a sec there's like menacing Li's
bun Nathan herbivore that dino has a
crotch ah yeah oh that is quite the
protuberance yes protuberance aah what
are you doing why
meaning what underwater and I thought I
was getting stepped on really thought
what it's tempt no no no what is stamped
do feel like step East OMPs step e
stumps ah step e stumps you know step e
stomps weird s step e stops steps and
stop ever I'm gonna just get more wood
until I can finally find a way to do
whatever I need to do we should take um
some of those wood and go back to that
place and use their furnace to make coal
so we can make torches yes that would be
great how do we do that
that now that's getting somewhere wait
that's usually doing can put the wood
logs in the furnace and it makes a hole
instantly pretty much hmm it's not
instantly is it I mean you put it in
there and it burns for a second then it
turns to cold
you put the wood in you take the wood
out you shimmy shammying then you shake
it all about dark where was this place
ready here you doofus how can you not
see this wait you go what paid no wait
I'm just here alone with the audience I
see it I see them they're all looking at
me I'm here I think I need to do
something funny they're all looking at
me
wait there's already oh hi wait okay now
that you're here they don't have to look
just at me I was panicking oh they're
gonna do something tear you were do
something funny
I can't no how dare I do something funny
I would never put a grab it's not glued
up do you yeah exactly I'm so funny man
who's gonna play we should play some
dive cake number one how much fun we had
last time
yeah dive gig was great how about you
shut up go ahead I drank it too
you drank it to you I don't know what
okay um beautiful dress I know you
already did but wood planks are wood
logs in just long Oh
oh my god charcoal right away holy
crapola it's just a stick use a log in a
charcoal to make a torch oh my god I'm
gonna put my crafting table down right
yeah yeah I'll just hope the people that
live here don't come back
Oh too close to a player structure what
the hell is that me oh okay well they
claimed this no no I got it Boop got it
dingdong this isn't part of their
structure apparently not don't ask
questions you don't want the answers to
flourish
I need to charcoal there's some bull
who's some dinoball view nine Obul yeah
Dino bull that sounds delicious thank
you I know I am
cuz I'm pretty much 100% bald I know the
lung camera for a second she's sitting
behind me no way I don't know
okay I got a torch now enemy players
will be able to see me from miles away
like I realized instantly wonder if you
can actually carry a torch if you have
to set it down I hope oh my god
set it down you can't hold it your hand
get hold him it's floating above me
Allred ah was the borders ahh
I'm losing my mind wait
I got Domino's fevered where's the
charcoal that you should have made I
took it out I made a torch Kip places
here it's too close to a player
structure don't forget your crafting
table
oh yeah well can't you get it God I got
everything you want it I got it I got it
let's go
we're done arrows go it's the Sun up yet
nope god damn it
hahaha who's my pretty 9 Oh God are you
barely keep up with you oh yeah my slick
rhymes is too fast and too amazing play
dry him down my slick rhymes my slick
rhymes Griff Rick Rick Grimes you don't
even want to know the walkers you've
gone Dino gon die no I've lost my mind
I'm going crazy I lost my mind I'm going
crazy I don't feel okay I don't even
have enough energy to do that good good
good
really where'd you go wait oh there
you're right behind what the hell do we
do here's a rock Hannah oh it's a rock
oh my god it's beautiful
did we hit it with our dime yep oh my
god what how do we wear the rocks to
come out of it um the whole thing breaks
apart of you it is what does that even
mean
I mean it means you hit the rock with
your knife and then pieces will break
off with you see a hand icon you can
pick it up oh whoa whoa whoa whoa then I
was
up G gigantic rocks I digged in a rock I
just got unidentified or what wait a
minute you picked it up I thought I got
some of that you're gonna have any rocks
you don't have any no I don't have any
remedy I thought I picked some up here
I'll place them to a torch scare this
dino Oh Dino we're scientifically
superior to you both ah take that stuff
ah get scared Dino yeah run away what a
BA oh oh he's a sweetie oh he's a
sweetheart is a structure that's a bad
idea Rebecca the structure with our
honored I defy door
oh you want our blood Oh dad no you're
dead ha ha dad what did I die what
happened
Oh attack Annette has jumped at it it
was in the structure I was in it yeah
they can go through it they just clip
through Oh bull honkey pissin boots
where are you now I'm well we're gonna
lock finding each other in the dark I
think that's just gotta be the end of
this episode I think I found where oil
is pouring out of the ground
Wow let oh my torch is right here I
spelled right by that torch wait did you
wait I did hair wine
oh I'm still alive hot clothes wait
okay all right we're gonna end it so
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been beasts of prey with Wade
thanks for being of no help to this
entire game it's very helpful I got you
a torch you got me to chop wood and
rocks and usual we didn't get any of the
rocks that's not my fault
well you didn't you got out identify
doors bribe you picking it up you're too
stupid to look at your like you are
giving us a rock were a potato can I get
mmm no yeah that's right all right so
either way thanks again everybody for
watching we're gonna play a little board
but we're gonna go find another server
that's dead
and hopefully we can try this again so
thank you to everybody and as always we
will see you in the next video bye bye
see you guys